yeah before you want to hear about the
story where you were chased by the cops
and you pissed yourself yeah I pissed
myself like 12 times that night trying
to stay warm but explain the build up to
that all right so we're coming from
bazoya and we're going into Lake Jackson
and uh
these are small country towns and I
remember I'm riding in the car you got
it
crazy huh yeah
this is I don't know I'm waiting for her
to send some more okay go on anyways uh
oh yeah we're coming from Missouri and
Lake Jackson and somebody driving
passenger seat somebody right here and
I'm right here behind the passenger seat
and uh I know these dudes but they all
know each other better you know what I'm
saying like they grew up with each other
I'm kind of just like I'm cool with them
you know what I'm saying and uh
and I I got some slides on that I just
got for Christmas like they think we're
like champ slides some socks pants with
no underwear and a jacket with no shirt
on a super zip up Jaguars no shirt and
uh I'm skinny at the time
and uh
we get put up I see lights and I'm like
oh [__] girlfriend get his ticket we can
get right back on and uh
he he [__] they all three look at
each other and I was like oh [__] you
know what's up and they get this book
back and they throw it on me and they're
like man you gotta run ain't gonna hold
you cuz and within that play I'm [__]
up you know so within that Split Second
of me being [__] up and trying to
think about it I'm like [__] I'm either
hey y'all they finna come to this car
they probably weren't even gonna search
us I would probably just tripping yeah
you know what I'm saying hey I was just
probably tripping and uh
and they they you know I either knew
that they're going to come they're gonna
search Us and nobody gonna own up to it
and if nobody owned up to it man
everybody going to jail you know because
it's in here we had it was it was some
[__] and uh
and [__]
I ain't love jumping out the cars like
[__] I gotta go I got a better chance of
just making it on my own so I [__]
grabbed a hoe and took it and [__] uh
I jumped the fence my slides fell off my
feet and I took off running and I'm
running on all this lands with the work
yeah and uh on somebody's land no yeah
running through the [__] and like I
[__] you know I run through a church
and I [__] uh you know what I'm
saying I do all this extra [__] I had to
swim while you're high yeah high as [__]
I had to swing through uh
swim to [__] a river to get to the
other side of the land I'm in this water
I'm trying to hold on to a bar under the
bridge you know what I'm saying because
like I'm trying to like stay underwater
you know what I'm saying because I'm
thinking they coming after me and I see
these lights
and uh
I'm like [__] right here you know it's
it's the end I'm just praying just
[__] praying like dog why am I here
why am I in this [__] and uh and cause
I'm going just to go [__] up some
shorties you know like this was not on
my agenda the
I ended up getting out the water I poked
my head out and I see the lights are
gone I'm like [__] they probably got
them off and they're thinking I'm gonna
get out thinking that they're gone
so I'm sitting in Haven longer and it's
cold as [__] the wind's blowing it's
[__] raining you know what I'm saying
and they're like [__] it he's in the
woods I'm sure that's why they live like
you got to say like it was a rainy ass
night that night it was cold as [__] the
wind blowing all this [__] and there's
hogs out there they're not worried about
me no more I'm deep in there
and I'm running I'm running I remember
giving up I just laid down I had
cottonmouth I'm like [__] like I laid
there like [__] they just gonna come get
me no fully gave up and then I laid
there for like five seconds ten seconds
I said a quick ass player got up and I
kept running and [__]
you know keep running I'm [__]
running through a I'm running in like
about ankle deep water now you know what
I'm saying I had to jump a barbed wire
fence and cut the crotch with my pants
all the way to my ankle leg so now this
whole entire leg getting smacked by cold
ass winding
hell yeah I had to [__] like military
cross the land so people wouldn't see me
you know I was [__] off whoa yeah it
was crazy cold as [__] ended up laying
down right here and I [__]
I was kept falling asleep and I'd
[__] doze off and like every dream
that I had I was at my grandpa's house
but it I was always way I would always
dream of being in a different area so
like our first dream I was on the back
patio and I was smoking with them and
I'm like all right grandpa I'm gonna go
to bed and then you ever go to your bed
and just kind of like just just drop on
it yeah so I'll do that and every time
boom I hit the bed oh I wake up every
and and I had that drink like five times
eventually I just got [__] mad and
woke up and got back on the run I'm like
[__] that dream bro while I'm sleeping
I'm [__] I'd wake up and I was just
pissed and I keep my hands right here
like I'd [__] I try to keep it you
know keep on
and it's cold as [__] all this rain hit
me and [__] so I'm pissing like a
[__] you know
everything worked out you got away yeah
hell yeah I ended up getting to my
cousin's house like it and [__]
had like take my clothes off for me
because I was like so weak I had to jump
in the show I was sick as foot for like
two weeks after that yeah and what
happened to the guys you were with
hell yeah the first thing they asked me
was where's the [__] what'd you say I
said it's [__] gone but if if I had
it it's mine
oh did you have it hell no I threw it in
that water I didn't get caught with it
oh that's crazy have you ever been
arrested yeah hell yeah oh really yeah
but like but man get me out of the hop
on that quick why
hell no bro no no TV no phone I can't go
without my phone you know what I'm
saying I got a [__] in front of
everybody I don't mind [__] in front I
ain't gonna lie never mind
I'll [__] on the side of the road one
time I was walking to the complex and I
was like I just had the BG's and I
couldn't hold it [__] took my shirt off
wiped my ass went right back we played
soccer that night
with your own shirt bro I want shirtless
you wiped your ass with the shirt
on a cold night some criminal probably
ran through that [__] and was like let's
keep my toes
nice shirt I found full of [__] what's
one man's trash is the next man's come
up exactly
that is crazy man bro what a life